Speaker 1: . Let's go to Tavis from India.
Tavis, welcome. What part of India are you from?
Speaker 3: Uncle Pondicherry.
Speaker 1: Which region is that?
Speaker 3: It's in southern India. It was
colonized by the French. Oh, I'll look into it.
Speaker 1: Actually, I should. That sounds
interesting. Is the cuisine more French?
Speaker 3: Oh, nothing particular like that.
But there are French cafes and stuff. No,
you won't find interesting is that there was like
a Tintin story that was based over here as well.
Speaker 1: A Tintin store. That's interesting.
Yeah. All right. Well, what's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: I want to ask you what your thoughts
are on immigration like, because a lot of right
wingers accused the left of being open borders
and like just free flowing immigration. So do
you think that like there should be some limit
on immigration or do you think that it should be
an easy process or what exactly?
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah. I mean, listen,
my position on this is not unique to the
United States. Countries have every right
and responsibility to set immigration policy.
You they have every right and responsibility to
enforce the fact that they have borders and to
establish what is the path to citizenship and
how many years or what what would be disqualifying
factors all of. Absolutely, of course, that that
should happen. What I where I think the problems
are include what right wingers want to do in terms
of using immigration to as some of them want to
do it, allowing only white people or mostly white
people to have these xenophobic and racist quota
systems to use immigration as a political tool
in order to try to shape the electorate in a
way that you believe is advantageous to you.
The idea of deporting individuals who were
brought here as kids by undocumented parents
through no fault of their own, that's completely
immoral and wrong to do so. They should get a
path to citizenship. But of course, yeah,
countries can have immigration policy.
They can say, here's the amount of immigration
that we can have. And of course, I,
I am I have not actually even met anyone
who is like actually an open borders person.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Because like, there are a few
leftists I've seen who are they want to restrict
immigration because they believe that, you know,
it depresses wages and things like that. So I do
believe that is central to why they want to
restrict immigration. But I see that like
there is a bit of xenophobia, which is that they
want to preserve America as an Anglo-Saxon white
nation. Is there any truth to that?
Speaker 1: Is there any truth to which part?
Speaker 3: To like actually both sides
that the left doesn't want immigration
because of economic reasons and the right
is wanted because of cultural reasons.
Speaker 1: There's true there, of course, there
is truth to both of those things. You know, on
the wages. The truth is that the degree to which
immigration influences wages is very, very modest.
This has been studied extensively, and we have a
long form piece about it on our YouTube channel.
And I also have there's a couple of books on my
reading list. If you go to David Pakman dot com
slash economics, I have a list of economics books
that I recommend and several of them deal with
this issue of immigration and wages. It has almost
no impact, and much more of an impact is from
corporations that are willing to illegally hire
undocumented workers. That depresses wages much
more than actual legal immigrants coming in.
Speaker 3: Right? Right. Yeah. Okay.
Thank you for taking the question.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. There's Tavis from
India. I mean, I have to research that French
part of India. That's very, very interesting